the Palestinian ambassador to the U.N is
going to be speaking with us
and also the Arab representative in the
security Council uh
ambassador from United Arab Everett is
with us along with the representatives
from Egypt Jordan and Algeria
we have finished as the delegation of
the State of Palestine
a meeting with the president of the
security Council
the ambassador of Switzerland
and her team
in which we have briefed her
about the latest developments
about the criminal aggression against
our people
in the Gaza Strip
in the early hours of yesterday
in which in a cowardly fashion
13 Palestinians in the span of 20
seconds were assassinated among them
children and women
sleeping in their apartments in the Gaza
Strip
and of course the ensuing events as we
are observing until this moment of
course we condemn this crime
we condemn those who committed these
crimes particularly killing large number
of children and women
and we believe that it is the duty of
the security Council
to condemn these crimes
and to uh pronounce that those from the
Israeli side who planned these crimes
who have committed these crimes should
face
accountability and should pay for their
crimes
we are grateful that our brothers from
United Arab Emirates
we asked them yesterday that the
security Council shoulder its
responsibility
and should the meet in a closed session
to discuss the situation
and should react and condemn this crime
we are grateful that they acted swiftly
with the president of the security
Council
and agreed to have a meeting in a closed
session this afternoon at 3 pm
endorsed along uh you know with the
United Arab Emirates China and France
and we are grateful to that
it happened
that there was a scheduled meeting
before the aggression
in which the Bureau of the Palestine
committee met with the e-10 yesterday
on a lunch business lunch
and in that meeting we had a very
constructive discussion
about the role of the security Council
and the role of the E10
water in relation to condemning this
aggression
and to see the security Council
shouldering its responsibility or with
regard to many other issues
stemming from providing protection to
our people
to uh seeing that the security Council
to pay an official visit
to the occupied Palestinian territory to
see with their own eyes the reality of
our people and the violations and
breaches of international law by the
occupying Authority Israel and the
criminality of the settlers
all these issues were raised you know
with the president of the security
Council
and that we know that many States
including many members in the security
Council issued National statements in
which they expressed their condemnation
or outrage because of the large number
of killing of children and women
and we appreciate these statements along
with the statement of the league of Arab
state
the Council of the league and also the
statement for the by the OIC and many
countries we know for for a fact that
there is no
country that respect the law that do not
condemned in the strongest possible term
the assassination and the killing of
innocent children while they are
sleeping in the labs of their moms and
dads in the middle of the night as was
the case yesterday morning in the Gaza
Strip
and uh in this connection also I want to
uh to express our appreciation
for a number of countries and the UN but
especially Egypt which was always
instrumental in brokering uh you know
stopping the onslaught and the
aggression of our aggression against our
people and they played an instrumental
role and are in brokering the ceasefire
that was put in place the last one
almost a week ago
and the Israeli government and their
army and their you know intelligence
connived in the middle of the night
during the last few days and broke the
ceasefire and organized this aggression
in violation to what they promised
others including Egypt of honoring and
respecting the ceasefire
we sincerely hope that this aggression
to stop against our people immediately
and we sincerely hope that the security
Council and the International Community
can condemn in clear terms the killing
of children and women and to go after
those who have uh organized this
massacre against them and to make them
face Justice and pay the price that they
deserve we will see what the security
Council will do after three o'clock
but we keep we will continue keep to
keep knocking on the door for the
security Council to shoulder its
responsibilities
they have many resolutions including
resolution 9-4
that calls for providing protection for
the civilian population until the end of
the occupation
that resolution contains significant
Provisions in it one it calls for
disarming the settlers that was adopted
almost 29 years ago not building a new
Army of 25
000 militia of settlers and to give them
more more weapons what is needed is to
take what the weapons from the hand of
the settlers who are killing our people
and threatening their lives the second
element in that resolution
is calling for temporary International
presence in the occupied Palestinian
territory we need protection from this
Savage attacks by the Israeli Army and
the settlers
what are enables Engineering in Jericho
in Jerusalem and Ramallah in Bethlehem
in Khalil and in every part of the
occupied Palestinian territory and
definitely we need them to stop their
aggressions and attacks against our
people in the besieged Gaza Strip as we
have seen since you know the early hours
of yesterday
this is what I wanted to share with you
I'm sure that some of you want me to say
something in Arabic we will but I want
to give the opportunity to anyone from
my colleagues if they wish to say
something to do so
thank you
um I think
um Ambassador yatman Source said it all
Security Council has a responsibility uh
for the maintenance of peace and
security around the world and this is a
clear case that the security Council
much must shoulder that responsibility
the state of Kuwait has condemned in the
strongest of terms this aggression and
the continued aggression against the
Palestinian people calling on the full
implementation of Security Council
resolutions in this regard and the need
to safeguard the rights and the
protections afforded to the Palestinian
people as it is afforded to everyone
else according to the Charter of the
United Nations and international law the
responsibilities are clear the
condemnation must be absolute and by all
and the protection of civilians both in
the in the physical sense and in the
legal sense must be something that the
security Council takes up and we stand
in full solidarity with our Palestinian
Brethren and will continue to support
their just cause
um just to confirm that the UAE did in
fact along with
um France and China call for a meeting
of the security Council which will take
place at 3 pm today the call was
supported by the Russian Federation
um and uh you know we're back yet again
calling for a meeting due to the uh very
concerning developments uh in the
occupied Palestinian territory
um the UAE
condemns strongly the airstrikes that
have caused the deaths of civilians
which include women and children
um these are unacceptable
the security Council does have a
responsibility to
um call for
intensified dialogue to call for
de-escalation to
um
do whatever it can to prevent further
violence I think we're already seeing
the situation
um spin
into a circle of violence and
we would very much encourage all the
parties to de-escalate we commend the
efforts of the
um of Egypt in
calling for calm and then mediating
among the parties and we very much hope
that
the that we will be able to avoid the
circle of violence that it looks like
we're heading into
okay
father
you're watching Argentina we've been
bringing you a press conference that's
been uh hosted by the Palestinian
ambassador to the U.N Riyadh Mansour who
has been talking about the meeting that
has been held at the U.N with uh
involving the security Council to try to
discuss the situation between Israel and
Gaza that has been going on he described
um what he said was the criminal
aggression against people in the Gaza
Strip he also said we are going to keep
knocking on the door of the security
Council to shoulder its responsibilities
and he said also that the meeting had
been pulled together by the United Arab
Emirates who had acted with China and
France and had discussed the matter with
the president of the security Council
this is ahead of a U.N security Council
meeting which we is going to be
happening I believe at 3 P.M local time
uh in New York at the UN headquarters of
the security Council which was
pre-planned anyway to discuss this
situation I can bring in Kristen salumi
who is live at the UN headquarters for
us
um quite clearly Riyad Mansour they're
setting out what he regards as the
important agenda that the security
Council should be discussing when it
meets
that's absolutely right and he met first
with the president of the security
Council the uh ambassador from
Switzerland Pascal Beres well to convey
his concerns and his feelings along with
other members uh of the United Nations
the other Arab Representatives uh
ambassadors that are surrounding him at
this press conference to express their
concern uh he wants the security Council
to come out and condemn what happened as
well this will however be a closed-door
meeting the council will receive a
briefing on the situation from tour
Venezuelan the special coordinator for
the Middle East he's already condemned
the deaths of civilians from the Israeli
airstrikes in a statement that he
described them as unacceptable he called
on all of the parties to issue restraint
the secretary General's spokesperson sin
has also condemned the deaths of
civilians and also condemned targeting
of Civilian infrastructure now Israel
ahead of this meeting submitted a letter
to the security Council said it was
targeting members of the Palestinian
Islamic Jihad uh in that it had
succeeded in killing three of them no
mention in the Israeli letter of the
women and children who were killed in
those strikes
did however accuse the militants of
using uh
civilians as human Shields but we heard
from Mansour about children who had died
while sleeping in their mother's laps
and that is what he wanted to bring home
to the council here we don't expect any
outcome from this meeting but we may
hear more comments from other countries
after it has taken place Kristen thank
you very much indeed that's Kristen
sinumi bringing us up to date from un
headquarters